j'ai intégré à cannes en 2007 en tant
que technicienne l'hybridation erkan
c'est le centre de recherche de la
filière canne sucre à la réunion ce
centre de recherche a été fondée en 1929
et son coeur de métier c'est la création
variétale
la campagne d'hybridation commence au
mois de mai avec la récolte des fleurs
des cannes à sucre dans les champs on va
ensuite croiser ces différentes fleurs
obtenir des graines et ses graines
seront semées on obtiendra 120 2000
plantules qui on voit entretenir
jusqu'au mois de décembre et
lorsqu'elles seront assez grande on va
les envoyer dans nos pépinières sur les
différentes stations conte à travers
l'île une fois dans les pépinières les
plantules seront sélectionnés pendant 15
ans à l'issue de ces quinze ans on
choisira la meilleure variété qui sera
libéré
pendant l'intercampagne je m'occupe
principalement de préparer la campagne
suivante donc je m'occupe un peu de
l'approvisionnement et je mens aussi en
place quelques petites pestes qui me
permettront d'améliorer nos pratiques
ensuite
je traite aussi quelques données de la
campagne précédente
je suis fier d'avoir pu participer à
l'amélioration des pratiques qu'on a on
hybridation à aircal actuellement je
suis en train de mettre en place une
chambre de germination qui permettra
d'effectuer nos semis dans des
conditions optimales de germination
ce qui me plaît dans ce métier c'est que
je peux travailler dans différents
environnements tout le long de l'année
je travaille aussi bien dans les champs
cancer en laboratoire ou dans un bureau